[Music]
and away we go
from indy we're ready to run it back for
more march madness
and the whole dance is right here in the
great state of indiana
basketball is woven into the fabric of
this city
let the madness begin we've waited two
years for this and here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
their first ever ncaa victory
it's march expect the unexpected
[Applause]
[Music]
believe the unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
roberts the upset makers are history
makers
another fairytale ride let's go the wind
in your face
[Applause]
oh yeah over time bullseye
from the first four to the final four
the cougars are going to the final four
[Music]
it's been a long time coming
[Music]
[Applause]
they are unbeaten with history in their
crosshairs
[Music]
mitchell wants another three and he
finds it
[Music]
[Applause]
ties it with three sucks for the win
oh yeah there are onions jimin
onions what a kiss let's make a little
history tonight in indianapolis
butler oh right in the heart
coach drew and baylor
college basketball's greatest rebound
and rebuild with a championship